[Música]
a
el director del centro de control y
prevención de enfermedades robben red
ciudad dijo que durante los próximos 60
a 90 días eeuu tendrá más muertes al día
que los registrados tras los ataques
terroristas del 11 de septiembre ataques
donde murieron 2 mil 977 personas cifra
récord que se da en medio de la
aprobación de la vacuna de fisión y su
distribución que según expertos empezará
a principios de la próxima semana ups se
encargará de la distribución de la
vacuna al este de estados unidos
mientras que fedex lo hará para el oeste
del país 6,4 millones de dosis serán
distribuidas en las primeras 24 horas de
distribución entretanto la cifra de
muertos en eeuu es cercana a las 300.000
y el número de contagios es de casi 16
millones de personas además hay una
crisis hospitalaria porque un tercio de
los centros médicos en eeuu ya no tiene
unidades de cuidados intensivos
disponibles para atender a los pacientes
[Música]
rusias del cuarto país del mundo con más
casos confirmados de kobe 19 aquí las
navidades duran 10 días o más
eso implica muchos desplazamientos para
ver a la familia más posibilidades de
contagio el gobierno ruso se ha
planteado incluso restringir la
movilidad entre regiones y en moscú se
han suspendido todas las actividades
navideñas prácticamente en estos días se
aprecia un ligero descenso en el número
de contagios pero la capital rusa sigue
muy arriba en esa segunda ola estas
frías vacaciones rusas también suelen
conllevar un aumento del consumo de
alcohol un hábito que han desaconsejado
las autoridades sanitarias rusas a los
que se vayan a vacunar porque puede
obstaculizar la generación de
anticuerpos rusia ha inoculado ya a más
de 150.000 personas la vacuna contra la
cob in 19
[Música]
alemania registró este viernes un nuevo
récord nacional en el número de nuevos
casos de coronavirus en las últimas 24
horas también registró un nuevo récord
nacional en el número de nuevas muertes
por coronavirus en las últimas 24 horas
y esto se suma a que el 94% de los
distritos en el país actualmente son
considerados hot spots o zonas rojas
todo esto explica por qué las medidas
impuestas por el gobierno tanto aquí en
berlín como en las diferentes regiones
del país para frenar el avance de el
coronavirus simplemente no están dando
el resultado esperado es el octa un
parcial que está vigente desde
principios de noviembre y por el cual
los bares los restaurantes y los museos
debieron cerrar mientras que los
almacenes y los colegios permanecieron
abiertos de ahí que la pregunta en estos
momentos en alemán ya no es si las
autoridades van a tener que imponer
nuevas restricciones sino cuándo y qué
tipo de nuevas restricciones se habla
incluso de un lock down mucho más
completo similar al que vivió el país al
principio de la pandemia de tal manera
que los números de coronavirus puedan
reducirse
aquí en alemania
[Música]